en el segundo día de su gira
presidencial por medio oriente' joe
biden se reunió con yair lapid y
coincidieron en impedir que irán
desarrolle armas nucleares aunque con
matices en las formas el presidente
estadounidense defendió la vía
diplomática como la mejor manera
mientras que para el primer ministro
israelí eso no bastará y es necesario
que irán tema una respuesta militar
creíble si insiste en su plan nuclear
esta posibilidad no fue descartada como
un último recurso por bailén y hasta
quedó plasmada en la llamada declaración
de jerusalén que firmaron ambos
mandatarios la integración de israel en
medio oriente fue otro de los ejes
previstos lapida invito a que más
naciones árabes se normalicen relaciones
con israel mientras que bardem prometió
acercar al estado hebreo con arabia
saudita frente a las críticas por
aceptar reunirse con el príncipe
heredero mohamed bin salman baiden dijo
mantenerse como un defensor de los
derechos humanos y aclaró que no ha
cambiado su posición sobre el asesinato
del periodista llamado high ops y del
que la cia responsabiliza a la corona
saudí está relegado quedó el conflicto
palestino-israelí con apenas una mención
a la repetida solución de 12 y que para
eso será posible si israel está seguro
en la región pero a la vez el reafirmó
que jerusalén es la capital de israel lo
cual se sabe es inaceptable para los
palestinos la jornada se completó para
bardem con la recepción de la medalla de
honor del presidente israelí isaac
herzog un breve cara a cara con el líder
opositor benjamín netanyahu y una
participación en la apertura de los
juegos macabeos una suerte de olímpicos
judíos el viernes en bailén tendrá su
corto capítulo palestino de la gira con
una visita a un hospital en jerusalén
este y la reunión en belem con el
presidente palestino mahmud abás luego
partirá hacia su última parada en arabia
saudita